I LOVE COP MOVIES MY FAVORITE
HAS TO BE THE "LOUIS CANNON"
FRANCHISE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT?
YOU'VE SEEN IT.
IT FOLLOWS A BAD-ASS DETECTIVE
TO BRINGS HIS OWN BRAND OF
JUSTICE TO THE STREETS OF
CLEVELAND.
HERE TO DISCUSS THESE NEW POLICE
RESTRICTIONS WITH CLEVELAND IS
THE STAR OF "LOUIS CANNON"
FRANCHISE, BROCK FEDERICO.
BROCK FEDERICO, EVERYBODY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
THANKS FOR COMING TO THE SHOW,
BROCK.
BROCK, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THESE NEW RULES?
>> I THINK THEY'RE TERRIBLE,
LARRY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MY
LIVELIHOOD HERE.
I'M A METHOD ACTOR.
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
>> Larry: SURE, IT'S BASE THE
CONCEPT OF STANISLAVSKI--
>> THAT WAS RHETORICAL.
I NEED TO FOLLOW RECKLESS POLICE
TACTICS TO DO MY JOB.
NOBODY IS GOING TO PAY TO WATCH
A COP DEESCALATE A SITUATION AND
GO HOME HAPPY ABOUT HIS ROLE IN
THE COMMUNITY.
THEY WANT TO SEE ME TRAMPLE
CIVIL RIGHTS WHICH I DO IN
"LOUIS CANNON 3: CIVIL RIGHTS
TRAMPLER."
( LAUGHTER )
>> Larry: TRUE.
GOOD POINT.
>> THAT WAS A HIT, BRO.
>> Larry: WAIT, ISN'T THAT THE
ONE WHERE YOU KICK A BABY?
( LAUGHTER )
THAT ONE ACTUALLY REALLY
OFFENDED ME.
>> IT REALLY OFFENDED YOU.
100 MILLION OPENING WEEKEND.
TELL MY ACCOUNTANT YOU'RE
OFFENDED.
>> Larry: BROCK, LOOK, NOBODY
IS SAYING YOU CAN'T TO CRAZY
THINGS IN YOUR MOVIE ANYMORE,
IT'S JUST THAT REAL COPS
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T.
>> COME ON MAN.
YOU WOULDN'T DENY A PAINTER HIS
PAINT, RIGHT.
YOU WOULDN'T DENY A CHEF HIS
KNIVES.
WELL, MY KNIVES ARE GUNS.
>> Larry: WHAT?
>> THEY'RE THE TOOLS OF MY
TRADE, LARRY.
LOOK, I NEED MY CRAFT TO BE
AUTHENTIC.
RIGHT, AND NOW YOU'RE SAYING
COPS CAN'T PISTOL-WHIP PUNKS FOR
TALKING BACK ANYMORE?
RUINS THE ENTIRE PREMISE OF MY
NEXT MOVIE.
>> Larry: AND-- AND WHAT'S
THAT?
>> "LOUIS CANNON 7: REQUIEM FOR
A PUNK PISTOL-WHIPPER."
>> Larry: I SHOULD HAVE KNOWN,
I SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
OKAY.
NOW, BROCK--
( APPLAUSE ).
>> NO, NO, YOU'RE JUST
ENCOURAGING HIM.
WHY DO YOU NEED-- DO YOU NEED TO
PISTOL-WHIP PEOPLE ALL THE TIME?
>> BECAUSE I RUN OUT OF BULLETS,
LARRY.
I ONLY CARRY FOUR GUNS.
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO?
>> Larry: FOUR SEEMS LIKE WAY
TOO MANY GUNS.
>> YOU SAY THAT NOW, BUT ALL IT
TAKES IS ONE HIGH-SPEED
HELICOPTER VERSUS MOTORCYCLE
CHASE ON A WINDY MOUNTAIN ROAD
WITH LOTS OF TUNNELS, AND ALL
FOUR GUNS ARE EMPTY.
AND THEN IT'S PISTOL-WHIPPING
TIME.
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT, OKAY, OKAY.
LET'S TONE DOWN THE PISTOL
WHIPPING, ALL RIGHT?
CLEVELAND POLICE AREN'T EVEN
ALLOWED TO SHOOT AT MOVING
VEHICLES ANYMORE.
>> GODDAMN IT!
HOW DO YOU EXPECT ME TO WORK
UNDER THESE CONDITIONS?
I CAN'T BE A DIVORCED LONER
NEXT?
I CAN'T LINGER OVER MY DEAD
PARTNER'S GRAVE AND PROMISE TO
AVENGE HIM.
>> Larry: BROCK, RELAX.
I'M SAYING IF YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE AUTHENTIC YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO SCALE IT BACK
LIKE REAL COPS.
>> THAT'S ( BLEEP ), LARRY.
WHOLE POINT OF THE "LOUIS
CANNON" IS I PLACE A LOOSE MAN
NONE.
RULES MEAN NOTHING TO ME.
>> OKAY, CANNON, THAT'S ENOUGH.
IF YOU WANT TO KEEP PLAYING A
PRETEND OFFICERS YOU'RE GOING
HAVE TO PLAY BY THESE PRETEND
RULES.
PUT YOUR PROP BADGE AND PROP GUN
ON THE TABLE!
>> YOU GOTTA BE--
>> ON THE TABLE!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
COME ON, CANNON!
>> FINE.
WHAT AM I GOING TO DO?
I HAVE TO LISTEN TO THE ANGRY
BLACK LIEUTENANT.
( LAUGHTER )
SEE IF I CARE, BUT YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO STOP ME FROM DOING WORK
I LOVE.
SEE NUT FUNNY PAPERS, CHIEF.
GODDAMN IT!
IT'S HARD TO FLIP A REAL TABLE.
>> Larry: IT'S A REAL TABLE,
YEAH.
BROCK FEDERICO, EVERYBODY.
IT'S A REAL TABLE.
YOU CAN'T FLIP THIS OVER.